his music right now wow and uh i see
that it's a list called david's greatest
hits challenge
for those of you who have been following
the tour last season i did try and slip
in some song titles to the commentary
and magnus is listening to some of those
songs oh that's cool and here we go you
guys the oslo esports cup the first
major in the 2022 season has started and
uh david what's happening on the board
it's a sicilian defense skyer and uh
that means it's gonna be dynamic from
the start it's gonna be a lot of action
in this one uh duda opening with his
king's pawn magnus replying with a
sicilian and i'm expecting him to trade
a set of pawns in the center now there
we go capture and
this is called the khan variation it's
black just allowing white to take center
but black is going to set up a wall of
pawns it's going to heat up as the game
goes on there we see duda just taking a
few moments and eventually deciding to
bring his bishop out one of the main
moves and uh okay the moves speeding up
like developing bishop kicking white's
knight back and now parking his bishop
on a nice long diagonal yeah and uh i
have to say i'm very excited to see this
uh variation actually on the board
because
this bishop retreat is quite ambitious
but it does also have its risks and the
primarily one the primary one sorry is
the the fact that some pawns are left
undefended on the right side but duda
doesn't actually go for that instead
just uh moves his queen one square
forward pushing a pawn in the center
first for black okay he does bring out a
piece at some point white will castle
most likely on the king side often in
the sicilian we can see white decide
which side to castle on and his
intentions if they're really ambitious
he'll castle on the long side but first
he offers a trade of dark squared bishop
so duda may be surprised by magnus's
opening choice just taking a positional
approach on this last move and attacking
on both sides of the board so this is
this is a great start um exciting start
if we do see the kings parked on
opposite sides of the board as you
mentioned it's just going to be complete
chaos both sides throwing pawns against
each other's kings first magnus carson
just takes a step forward with one pawn
just solidifying the dark squares but a
bit slow so there must be something here
down the line that he's thought about oh
and simon you're going to be happy with
this last move white knight has just
developed itself but that has cleared
the path for the white king to castle on
the queenside on the long side and okay
moment of truth which side is that white
king going if dude castle's left with
the king he's going on the attack he
wants to win and maybe we'll see a
situation where magnus is under pressure
and uh facing a big attack very quickly
if duda castle's on the right side of
the board though and okay he's delayed
the decision simon are you happy to see
this one f for forward the f pawn has
marched forward maybe preempting the
march of the g pawn as well because if
you're going to beat magnus you can't be
second guessing yourself
and okay magnus decides not to commit
his king and instead concentrate on
developing the light squad bishop
and oh after a long pause we do have a
move yeah and
duda continues to procrastinate he
hasn't chosen which side to put his king
on and
like simon said you can't delay it too
much longer with white soon the position
will open up or soon black will be fully
ready uh to kind of create some threats
and the longer white's king sits in the
center the longer he delays the decision
i think uh he's just gonna miss his
chance this move i only played once
before in a junior tournament i think
it's just that it's the first game of
the tournament the first game of the day
and duda just wasn't really warmed up
enough to go straight for the attack
straight for the kill maybe playing the
world champion he thought okay let's
just grow into the game and get in the
flow a bit later on but sometimes early
days you still have to attack you still
have to go for it and magnus now has
blocked up the center what do we think
of this move if you could kind of pick
up this knight and put it on this square
or this square then it would be really
dangerous black is just weak in those
squares but okay dude after another long
think does to decide to trade bishops
and uh after black recaptures this rick
actually on a decent square can swing
across now
white has blocked things up so this is
the key moment can black break open the
center or does he have to wait and
prepare that for a move or two if you're
going to this sharp open sicilian
probably one of the sharpest openings
you can get
the tempo increases so you don't really
have time to play like a3 uh the move
that dude have played generally i think
it was just not much else choice uh not
much uh else to do if black hood castled
kingside in this position then suddenly
white will start to unleash the pawns
push them forward so i think he's just
trying to counter uh counter against
this and by trading pieces remember
black is still a bit cramped this bishop
in particular can't develop itself to a
good square while you're cramped you
want to trade pieces and want to swap
things off and now some crazy stuff is
happening on the board could be a
valuation bar i mean is that is that
yeah okay let's catch up with the
position this knight was attacking the
queen we saw a trade and here duda has
instead of moving his knight which was
under fire just moved his queen to the
side
eyeing up the rook on long this diagonal
but can magnus just grab this knight
maybe you can just give away your rook
here and after you take this pawn
threatening the rook threatening to
promote maybe there's some
counter-attack maybe a queen check maybe
the white king suddenly is in big danger
in the middle of the board it's
really committal to take the white
knight to sacrifice material then
okay magnus has done it we see the moose
very quickly magnus has sacrificed a
rook for a knight so black is down on
material now but look at that black pawn
it's attacking the rook in the corner
wants to make a new queen and no matter
where white's rook runs away to now
black's queen is going to jump forward
it's going to pounce check the white
king black's king at some point is just
going to castle and white king is going
to be eternally
in danger this is kind of typical for a
sicilian when it goes wrong for white
suddenly do some counter blow
and magnus is just unleashing here um
this you know even if black simply
castles which he has done the rook can
come to the middle white's king is stuck
in in this bad position and black has
has
great attacking possibilities here i'd
say bringing his queen in and uh this
would have prevented duda's last move
re-centralizing the white queen and
suddenly this pawn is going to win the
game long term magnus let this born
disappear he let it go he castled
instead and now after the white queen
retreated yes black gets his rook to the
open file hitting the white king
indirectly but this pawn is now doomed
he's just gambling going all in on an
attack against the white king and look
at this dude he didn't castle with his
king he couldn't he wasn't allowed to so
now he's brought his rook across and his
idea is to castle by hand as we call it
dropping his king back and then
shuffling it off into the corner so it's
long-winded but it's necessary and
magnus needs to strike now if he'd spent
his time just two moves ago he would
have probably won already but spending
his time now didn't necessarily help too
much so the move we showed was played
black bishop came out took a pawn that
was possible because of a pin and now
white's king is run away so now black's
bishop is under fire from that white
pawn in the center of the board and
actually magnus retreats the bishop
maybe he didn't spot this opportunity
his bishops on a decent square i i guess
it's like you said simon he saw that the
bishop wasn't attacked but he couldn't
find anything useful to do maybe he was
unsure about bringing the black queen in
now he has gone and grabbed a pawn but
there we go the evaluation bar now on
white side and this is what we were
warning about
yes black had an attack for a while
white king was feeling really unsafe but
suddenly if we do that count white has
an extra rook black only has a knight
and a pawn in return i feel would be
something white wants to do he's he's
not going to be in any immediate danger
then he has two rooks two rooks
incredibly good uh later on okay but
he's threatening to win the queen
instead yeah right wow bit of a strange
move there but white does have a threat
of bringing his rook in the middle of
the board all the way across and
trapping the black queen and there you
can see
magnus has actually just retreated his
queen and we can see mama jaroff in full
focus mode happening there you see queen
takes pawn and if you've been winning
and you let it slip it's the worst kind
of feeling because you've done this all
to yourself why did i allow that queen
into the middle of the board
so i was thinking the best thing i ever
saw was someone with a score sheet at
the end of the game that is such a good
way to
show your depression just make a little
paper airplane and
right in your opponents yeah that must
be a good feeling though and a few moves
on the board what's happening david yeah
things are heating up on the board and
also the clock look at this both players
now around the two-minute mark and uh as
simon pointed out white's queen went and
grabbed a pawn now it is a rook for a
knight in a pawn that's the material
balance so white ahead on material but
this black knight may be creating some
threats at the very minimum black's
knight is going to go back to the e5
square and plant itself on a nice
outpost magnus carlson he loves kind of
having strategic long-term compensation
he doesn't mind being points down
material down uh he just wants good
pieces and that black knight is going to
be a good piece and there we see duda is
bored dude has his board really big on
that huge screen magnus had it much
smaller that's really interesting uh for
me but uh okay under a minute to the
clock he needs to speed up this position
is getting critical 40 seconds i didn't
realize he was so low 40 seconds wow
okay minimum just push a pawn kick that
night out of your heart for the board
kick there we go that's the most obvious
move they're only next door he probably
hurt you
no no no we can guarantee there is a
soundproof
my point is that that was the most
obvious move but it cost him most of his
remaining time and now duda is going to
be eternally in time trouble down to 40
seconds
yes he's helped that black knight back
to the central board but it was more
important to kick it away especially low
on time you don't want a knight parked
in front of you in your face near your
king and uh okay he has kicked back that
black knight and now the white queen has
stepped back black's queen needs to jump
in i was about to say i'm in before it's
too late getting queen was almost
trapped very interesting now extremely
interesting i mean as you frank point
out the white king is a little bit
exposed uh but duda has controlled the
center of the board here that black
knight isn't really under threat if
white's
rook takes that black knight in the next
move black's queen can actually just
drop back on the diagonal and check the
white king but no solidity is magnus's
middle name and he's just solidified
that black knight and a queen trait
black's knight is super strong after all
but trading the queens means it's going
to be very one-sided the white rooks
will eventually come into the element so
maybe that black queen has to go in the
direction it came from back on that
diagonal preserve itself what is magnus
thinking about there we go he does
eventually retreat his queen and duda
continues to centralize his pieces as
well
yeah i mean magnus's knight is such a
beast of uh a beast of a piece there in
the middle of the board is supported by
the pawn it's a beautiful beautiful uh
you know know in a position beautiful
position and the bishops come around as
well but still still just all to play
for here i think it's uh it could go any
result as possible right um yeah now
magnus
oh leaving the night i mean we were
waxing lyrical about this night yeah why
did his eye is when he made that move
dude his eyes just widened like why has
he moved his great light to be traded
off that's very strange i mean why the
the knight can never be
budged from the center of the ball
because it couldn't have been attacked
by a white pawn uh and he's he's just
moved it there i mean even the rook
going up one square now it is only going
to help white's position
very strange just take that just take it
off take it off the ball move the king
onto a dark square protecting the rook
as long as you've got that cover 15
seconds for judah yeah 16 seconds oh he
doesn't take that black knight this is a
really strange move by dude he could
have kept things super simple he's
attacking the black queen though yeah
it's encouraging the queen to come
forward yeah
some stuff to calculate there i'm not
sure yeah oh maybe the black queen can
jump back into the position maybe the
black queen just has to retreat either
way next move dude will be itching to
get rid of that black knight
he's gone in so now if the queen's come
okay this is a clever check because
magnus needs to keep the queens on uh
otherwise he's gonna really really
struggle here
and uh okay
now duda he has a one trap mind he's
gonna try and trade pieces because his
rook long term is going to be better
than black's bishop to my eyes it
doesn't look like a great piece
well queens and knights combine far
better than queens and bishops as well
so very very strange by magnus there i
agree with you both there but i mean i
i'm not that pessimistic about magnus's
position just because you know the white
king is so shaky if white tries to get
even a you know even a little bit
ambitious
it can't do it yeah i might use both the
rook and the queen because there's
danger of perpetual check i guess white
has to try to play eat this pawn break
in the center and open up the rook uh
that's that's something i'd be trying to
do if i was white here um but you're
mean okay this is a good move for magnus
stopping those opportunities
okay he's going for another idea here
trying to trying to swap the queens off
in a crafty crafty little check uh over
towards the black king yeah if white can
retreat the queen now back to the f5
square next to the black queen swap it
off then white is gonna win the rook
will beat the bishop
but magnus can maybe just use his queen
put it on a different square dodge that
check maybe he can even move the black
king
some options here he needs to avoid that
trade okay he retreats his bishop back
to cover
any potential checking squares from the
white queen duda meanwhile exhaling
there maybe not so happy i think due to
mr trick just two moves ago he could
have brought his queen back to the
center of the board to stop black's
queen occupying this dream square look
at black's queen he was shaking his head
there wasn't he yeah i mean and now and
now past pawns need to be pushed
actually has a clear run through two
seconds seven seconds as well not that
much time for dude he has to make a move
and uh panic it just feels like it's
starting to set him yeah yeah i mean
it's all about centralizing queens and
magnus is the best player in the world
when it comes to centralizing queens
other players forget sometimes and now
white queen stuck behind its pawns it's
only protecting things black queen
dominant on the dark squares black
bishop dominant on the light squares i
mean you'd like two seconds for dude two
seconds
he's gonna move he made it with two
seconds left
he's quite a cool customer still isn't
he i mean like
he's not looking that cool actually
i say he's pretty cool but i mean there
is a limit oh
wow i think it's a big mistake and look
at this black can continue pushing his
pawn because now if white's rook goes up
to capture one of the black pawns this
pawn will continue pushing down the
board black is almost about to make a
new queen and how does he do how does he
always do it magnus i mean you always i
always think oh he's he's going to
struggle to you know draw this one and
then he goes on to win yeah
maybe there's a few winning moves but
black can push his b pawn forward now
connect those two there we go the points
connect white can't take that pawn with
his own pawn because the black queen
would pounce and take the white rook in
the corner these two black pawns are
just going to win the game white king
coming trying to ride to the rescue but
it's not going to be enough look at
those two pawns if white goes and
captures a pawn now there's going to be
a check from the black queen and white's
rook is going to drop
that one of those two black pawns is
going to cost white the rook magnus is
going to win harry and barry seconds
five seconds and
he might lose some time here he might
just lose on time because he's lost
anyway i mean is that it is it over yeah
it is over it's over okay did he
actually lose on time or did he just
resign i think he just let his clock run
out because it's a hopeless position
anyway